[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département
[Musique]
petit il est la septième communes de
l'île a signé avec le département le
pacte de solidarité territoriale
la commune dispose d'un budget de 1
million trois cent mille euros en
investissement et de 24000 euros en
fonctionnement
une aide qui servira notamment à réparer
les dégâts causés par le passage de la
forte tempête tropicale fakir soit faite
les communaux comme ça d d aller à
réparer rapidement
ce sont des imprévus le président du
département et serge hoareau 10
président délégué à l'agriculture ont
inauguré la station de prétraitement des
eaux superficielles du bras de la plaine
une centrale qui favorisera l'irrigation
du littoral sud cette station de
prétraitement va permettre de limiter le
nombre de jours de fermeture de l'eau
pour l'irrigation ou même pour les
fermiers qui achètent de l'eau avec la
saphir vous le savez nous avons
l'obligation de donner de l'eau à 10 mt
eu aux fermiers aux agriculteurs et
lorsque nous avons de la kabylité
importante vers une forme de pluie dans
le bras de la plaine
l'eau arrive ici à haut niveau 2021
non qu il nous faut un temps de
prétraitement la station prend de l'eau
à 150 nt eu pour livrer à disons que ça
montre bien que nous allons pouvoir
gérer le temps de fermeture du périmètre
grâce à cet outil
il y as très bel équipement ce tueur qui
a été réalisée par le département de la
réunion
financé par l'union européenne plus de 7
millions de travaux pour amener l'eau
ici cette eau qui s'est bien sûr à
l'agriculture mais pas seulement
l'agriculture qui s'est aussi aux
communes et donc aux familles de
saint-pierre petites îles et des
communes environnantes
je tiens à dire ici on s'inscrit dans le
développement durable
parce que on amène de l'eau qui s'est
offert milhes aux agriculteurs aux
industriels mais on crée aussi de
l'énergie puisque cette énergie elle est
renouvelable c'est un bel outil de co
développement et de développement
durable il sait que nous avons les élus
du département se sont ensuite rendus
dans la commune de saint louis où en
présence du maire patrick mallet ils ont
inauguré l'extension haute du périmètre
irrigué du bras de cilaos sur les
secteurs de bellevue et de maison rouge
cette irrigation profitera notamment à
l'installation d'une quarantaine
d'agriculteurs
beaucoup de richesses en can en banane
et en maraîchage parce qu'on avait
besoin de nous ici de mieux travailler 2
trois verges de plus peut-être mais en
n'ayant plus de trois millions sept cent
mille euros c'est le budget alloué par
le département à la commune de saint
louis cyrille melchior et patrick malet
ont signé le pacte de solidarité
territoriale
c'est une grande joie si j'ai une
bouffée d'oxygène
c'est là
this man d'une politique de solidarité
voulu par la nouvelle présidente du
département et nous en sommes très
heureux
alors sur le
le pacte de solidarité territoriale en
investissement ce sont essentiellement
des travaux routiers pouvoir réparer les
dégâts du cyclone birgitta dumazy les
fakirs mais des travaux dans les écoles
quand je vois que le maire de saint
louis va me dis que je veux utiliser les
critiques du département fois améliorée
restauré et réaménagé les chemins
endommagés là je ne peux que
l'accompagner dans ses efforts et c'est
là tout l'esprit du pacte de solidarité
départementale c'est l'accompagnement
avec efficacité dans un souci de
rapidité
l'accompagnement des communes dans la
réhabilitation de leurs équipements de
proximité la 11e promotion de l'
académie des dalons à la plaine des cavs
a organisé un jeu de l'oie grandeur
nature sur le thème de l'homophobie
il ya des jeux de sportifs jeux
réflexion je t'adresse par les plus
tolérants à par rapport à ça d'accord
c'est maintenant d avoir des préjugés
mais maintenant on va commenter ça on
juge plus et maintenant comprendre
comment il se sent dans leur peau dont
une belle maintenant sais pas répond
donc c'est des gens comme tout
simplement
en quatre années de fonctionnement l'
académie des dalons à la plaine des
cafres a permis l'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 65 % des
jeunes qui ont suivi leur formation est
un très bel outil mais c'est sûr que
c'est une qui passent par cette passat
academy bassan de la russie est un peu
plus sûrs d'eux puisque justement le bus
et deux caisses qui se pose ce qu'ils
ont fait à dure un peu confiance dans la
société va reprennent justement est sûre
puisse aussi se remettre en question à
travers les ateliers et l'équipe qui les
accompagnent pour le bonus de cette
semaine on vous emmène découvrir la
route départementale 3 entre le tampon
et saint joseph
[Musique]